welcome the sensor time nipple game
are you excited called of course I'm
excited now behind us there are three
human tick as you know female nipples
are not allowed on television some
reason your challenge is decide whether
these nipples are female and need to be
fixed or for that are they male and
censorship does apply okay then yes I do
set the timer and time here we take
first nibble is that a man woman or a
mineral I think this was a man all right
George does not need to be censored
that's right now the next nipple okay
this one on you can touch it okay yeah
that's a woman to a lady shunted I see
right down the third nipple you can blow
on it right now run over to Mimi all
right this is just a warm-up Jacqueline
so example two and three and did not
censor the first nipple that's right all
right nipple number one please reveal
yourself
I can't raise a man it doesn't need to
be census nipple number to reveal
yourself oh you are incorrect
I really thought is not an issue that
needs to be centric it's hard because
men and women both have them I guess
that's the point of the game okay
therefore number three
reveal yourself the human body is
beautiful
local tight cool guava oblong beak we're
gonna I'm not gonna wanna remember what
it was perfect except for the genitals
which I think we can all agree are
discussed